ブーバー光
ブラックなぜで今日はね今僕は友達のおじさん友達の家に泊まらせてもらいに遊びに
いくのだなそいつにねそいつねちょっとあることを試したいと思っている
まあ薬物を始める大曲言うとしてはやっぱりこう ci とか友達とかそういう人から
のこの勧誘から始めちゃうっていうパターンが多いってこれは中学校で習った僕
ブーバーしほっちゃんっ
お入りがな感じでほとんど怪しい薬をどんどんその友達に勧めますで男立つは本当に
断れるかどうか何か良いですよね
果たして果たしてその結構僕に信頼を抱いている人にセック振りお勧めで断れるか断ら
れないか
断れるか断れないかをちょっと転生してみると思うん
準備するような簡単なお前たちもすぐ出来るこちらのおっさんっジャック付きポリ袋
ヨーグレット無理だとラムネ
もう3でからに何か早く points くれそうだなぁ
また中には雑草一環にねその怪しい薬っぽく見せられるかが勝負なんですよ
もうこれだけで危ないかな急い時はな胸だからねそういう薬じゃないから
月木8グレープパッドにも完全にそっち系のあるだからこんな感じです
これですよ
どうですか薬っぽいお菓子をチャックきては袋に入れていきます
うわぁおりやはいはーい
ブーブ皇ラティても voodoo ことはロスコのアースいく3を合図にピュードゥ
持った
ん
tan
ねえ道具が笑った
許氏が音声の道です頑張ってよくライ
強制がチャンネルの動画はなんとはなんとですねアジェ開いたよ
j て略すなん
おい
それね
ruby まあ薄暗いだって持ってエース5 ae なが g ですよ
がチーノヌー6興味を持ってるべっ持ってりゃいいいいなーいいなーいいなー
どんなひいっでそれじゃああーもう
はえーなにこれからジャンナッツですねすげー
いやもう試合本か持ってるわけで
この時させておりくださいよってくれ日飲んでください
君は知ってです
そうですがこれ
なぜそういう迷ったらそんな風にもなっている
うん口これだけ4グループ時には何なんだろこれ
気をつけなくなって
なんかめっちゃ
すごい
食べやすいため合わせるというかなんですけど
麻薬等ございで1回イッ
おっ
の方がでい
にゃん
4番ミランダ冷凍ございます
胸部し
います
一瞬でドラッグくれましたね警戒した方がいいという
保育すぎとかを普通に港水族て者4グループたちが薄いです
これまでお菓子ポッキーメールが実はそれ危ない薬とかってするね
気を付けて下さい普通に食べましたもんだからそうなのとかじゃなかった鈍くマイクを
持っているはけどそっちですかでそういう音もってないような人から故障って鴨居
こっちがよくれっっはっはっはっよく
no れってたら可愛いなんてたちが丸くってその後国会たんだったんでしょ
書けばよかったなと思うそこまで笹に語学ています
今チャーミンちゃんと並みのクオリティには来れないんですよそれ